bonsoir hélène alors je disais un
rassemblement il touche parce que
oui vous pouvez le voir ici l'ambiance
est beaucoup plus festive de ce côté de
la capitale le cortège est arrivé dans
le calme tout à l'heure devant le
ministère de la santé et ils sont
nombreux aujourd'hui encore à avoir
répondu à l'appel de florian philippot
certains sont même venus vient le convoi
de la liberté de marseille de l'île de
strasbourg ou encore de rennes ils sont
tous là pour deux ans
restrictions sanitaires du gouvernement
le port du masque le vaccin obligatoire
le pass
qu'ils appellent les basses de la honte
des mesures qu'ils jugent liberticide et
pourtant il ya trois jours le porte
parole du gouvernement gabriella del
annoncé la possible levée du pass
vaccinale fin mars début avril
pour florian philippot il s'agit ni plus
ni moins qu'une manoeuvre politique
écouter
circle et parker ce gouvernement qui a
déjà supprimé des choses pires omis
juste derrière et là on est surtout à
dijon l'élection présidentielle début
avril donc ils se moquent de nous en
fait il va suspendre le pentax inhalent
alors que le seuil ne s'est jamais
justifié ouais le suspens pourquoi il a
grandi jours avant ils sont payants ciel
et puis il a dit la levée il n'a pas dit
l'abrogation sans merci macron repasse
on a le droit de nouveau on le sait bien
à cette société du pass vaccinale des qr
codes et j'en veux par mois donc on se
mobilise pas que comble pas axial depuis
le début on se mobilise pour éviter de
tomber dans un monde de surveillance et
de contrôle un monde de qr code le monde
que back home accrocs avec sa clique
veut absolument nous imposer on le
refuse totalement
cette nouvelle mobilisation était aussi
l'occasion pour le candidat à la
présidentielle d'aborder son programme
avec en première ligne le président soir
sortie de la france de l'union
européenne mais en attendant le mois
d'avril un seul mot d'ordre pour le chef
des patriotes
résistance jusqu'au bout avec un nouveau
rendez-vous déjà donné pour samedi
prochain